so this is one of my opinion the most
impressive accent persuasion in history
Charles Darwin's book on the origin of
species an account of how species
evolved through natural selection it was
a controversial bombshell when it was
published in the 1860s as Darwin knew it
would be the theory of evolution
threatened the sacred unviable worldview
in which species were immutable and
organized into a design hierarchy with
humans at the top
Darwin told a friend while he was
preparing the book that arguing for
evolution felt like confessing a murder
so the book sparked years of furious and
often emotional debate the darwin's case
was so solid so full of years of
carefully collected observations and
well reasoned arguments that it ended up
persuading people within a decade the
majority of the scientific establishment
believed in evolution and the reason
that darwin's case was so convincing
even to an audience for the strong bias
against it was that Darwin had Scout
mindset he bent over backwards while
writing the book to notice arguments and
evidence that went against his theory he
followed what he called a golden rule of
research to fight against mode of
motivated reasoning I had also he wrote
during many years followed a golden rule
namely that whenever a published facts a
new observation or a thought came over
me which was opposed to my general
results to make a Memorandum of it
without failing at once because I had
found by experience that such facts and
thoughts were far more apt to escape
from the memory than favourable ones so
Darwin basically stressed tested his
theory for years within an inch of its
life
trying to notice all of the potential
objections to it and modifying and
improving the theory until it was really
solid and that's what made him so
persuasive if he had instead tried to
just convince himself that he was
totally right and you know win the day
by the power of confidence I don't think
he would have succeeded so basically I
think I've overconfidence as a crutch it
might help you in some situations for
sure but if you don't allow yourself to
indulge in it then you force yourself to
become actually competent you force
yourself to improve your theories until
they're actually solid and that works
better in the long run
there's a book called confidence by
Tomas tomorrow / music that makes
basically this point he says we mostly
have been brainwashed into thinking that
confidence will eventually cause
competence I think it's much more
appropriate to think of confidence as a
compensatory strategy for lower
competence and by the way it's funny to
read reviews of this book on Amazon
because it's it's called confidence and
there are all these reviewers who are
like one-star I bought this book cuz I
wanted to learn how to be confident me
all these whole point is like no you
shouldn't do that so I think if you want
to be influential and persuasive which
is a fine thing to want to be then in
addition to actually developing your
skill you should look for other ways to
be charismatic and persuasive that don't
come at the cost of damaging your mental
models of the world like improve your
posture and your speaking voice your
general presentation learn good social
skills expand your social comfort zone
through practice interestingly I just
came across paper called when
overconfidence is revealed to others
testing the status enhancement theory of
overconfidence by Anderson and at all
and from the abstract it seems to be
making the case that overconfidence is
useful that it makes you influential and
higher status but if you actually read
the paper there's a striking table of
the factors that increase people's
social status in these groups and the
actual measures of overconfidence per se
like how confident you said you were in
your claims how easy you claimed that
the task was for you and how confident
you claimed to be those are the
highlighted ones at the bottom they were
either not significant or barely
significant the things that mattered the
things that increased your status in the
group were the social things did you
participate a lot in the conversations
was your tone of voice confidence did
you seem relaxed and at ease and may be
you know it could well be the case that
being overconfident in your beliefs or
your skills is one mechanism that causes
those traits but it's certainly not the
only one and it seems much better to me
to just develop those skills directly
rather than trying to deceive yourself
into believing you're totally writing
awesome in order
to get social confidence as a side
effect